economía en directo América de France 24
nuevo bloque económico con Daniela
landón Daniela y una de las preguntas
también que se ha generado pues tras la
muerte de la reina Isabel segunda es Qué
pasará con los miles de millones de
billetes emitidos con el rostro de la
monarca Bueno ya sabemos que la reina se
ha representado en los billetes y en las
monedas británicos durante décadas y
también en decenas de otros lugares del
mundo esto como un recordatorio de ese
alcance colonial que ha tenido el
Imperio británico solo en Reino Unido
hay unos 4.700 millones de billetes por
valor de 82 mil millones de libras
esterlinas en circulación también hay
alrededor de 29 mil millones de monedas
ya el royalmente que es de su fabricante
oficial salió a aclarar que los billetes
y monedas actuales seguirán siendo de
curso legal Y que cuando pase el luto
hará más anuncios un dato que le tengo
es que también cambiarán los sellos de
la compañía Estatal de correos los
pasaportes y que en las monedas ahora
será Carlos III el aparezca obviamente
pero mirando hacia la izquierda la reina
miraba hacia la derecha pero de acuerdo
con la tradición que Data del siglo 17
Los Monarcas se deben Mostrar de perfil
y en dirección opuesta a sus presas
Daniela y no Además esto se va a
convertir y digamos en un negocio y
sobre todo para las coleccionistas
obviamente agarrando todos estos sellos
postales estos billetes esta monedas
como goles Bueno hay que ir a Reino
Unido hacerlo Daniela agarrar esos
billetes en otros países que va a pasar
pues las monedas de otras naciones que
cuentan con la reina van desde dólares
australianos canadienses y beliceños
también se actualizarán con el nuevo
monarca otro dato en su momento Isabel
segunda llegó a aparecer en 33 monedas
diferentes más que otro monarca y ganó
un récord guinness el banco de Canadá
dijo que su billete actual de 20 dólares
está diseñado para circular en los
próximos años la Tico curioso 1935 antes
de subir al Trono la entonces princesa
de poco menos de 9 años aparecía en el
billete de 20 después fue actualizado
por supuesto el banco de la reserva de
Nueva Zelanda dijo que emitirá todas sus
existencias de monedas con la imagen de
la reina antes de que salgan con las
nuevas de Carlos III y el banco de
Australia aseguró que en algún momento
en 2023 ya Carlos III estará en las
monedas escuchemos
no tenemos la intención de acuñar
ninguna moneda en 2023 con la imagen de
la reina Pero estamos en un periodo de
transición hay algunas monedas que están
disponibles ahora con fecha de 2023 y la
reina son coleccionables y de inversión
las monedas se lanzan normalmente en
septiembre de cada año para el año
siguiente por lo tanto ciertamente no es
nuestra intención emitir más monedas con
fecha de 2023 y la epigía actual
cambiamos Ana información porque
Alemania Busca una reforma al mercado
eléctrico para este invierno bueno como
hay menos gas desde por cuenta de la
invasión de Ucrania esto ha disparado el
precio del combustible y ha arrastrado
consigo el costo de la electricidad en
varios países en Europa del mercado
eléctrico funciona de la siguiente
manera se hace una subasta y a todos los
generadores se les paga el precio del
que produzca energía a mayor valor que
en este caso es el gas pero la comisión
Europea y países también quieren que la
situación cambie
hemos tomado la decisión de reformar el
mercado eléctrico es inconcebible que
quienes producen electricidad con
energía eólica solar hidráulica carbón o
nuclear de van a obtener ganancias extra
porque el precio se determina según la
electricidad producida con gas
realizando Este cambio de acuerdo con la
Unión Europea que ha elaborado
exactamente la misma propuesta que
publicamos hace unos días ahora
implementaremos medidas para reducir el
precio de la electricidad para los
consumidores y grandes empresas y pueden
tener la seguridad de que lo haremos con
la velocidad necesaria para tener la
situación bajo control este invierno y
la organización Internacional del
trabajo Daniela encendió las alertas a
por lo que llama la esclavitud moderna
Pues eso que es la división laboral de
Naciones Unidas clasifica esas
esclavitud moderna en dos en trabajo
forzado y en matrimonio forzado
afectaban Entonces al cierre de 2021 a
50 millones de personas en todo el mundo
25% más que en la más reciente medición
que Data de hace cinco años del total se
estima que 28 millones de personas
sufrieron un trabajo forzado y el resto
fueron obligadas a casarse en el primer
caso la oit señaló tendencias
preocupantes como la explotación sexual
comercial que toca a una de cada cuatro
personas sujetas a trabajos forzados en
cuanto al matrimonio forzado Afganistán
bangladesh y República democrática del
Congo Egipto India uganda y yemen son
los más afectados sin embargo los países
más ricos no son inmunes a este problema
dice la organización Internacional del
trabajo vamos a hablar de los
indicadores económicos datos frescos
como le gustan a usted Raúl Wall Street
abrió fuertemente a la baja casi un 3%
solamente en su índice tecnológico no
vio con buenos ojos al mercado estos
datos que muestran que la inflación
volvió a desacelerarse en agosto por
segundo mes consecutivos situó su tasa
interanual en 8,3%, dos décimas menos
que en julio Pero el mercado no le
convence este dato también hace que en
Europa las bolsas se encaminen a un
cierre negativo con el ibex 35 de España
cayendo más del 1%. hacia tuvo un cierre
mixto antes de que se conociera la
información que Como se muestra en este
momento pues deja muy preocupado al
mercado sobre que la Fed pueda
eventualmente seguir más agresiva al
resto del año Dani como siempre Gracias
por toda la información económica mañana
Claro que sí más economía aquí en
directo América de Francia 24